You are a single eligible bachelor.
What would it take for
you to date during COVID?
To date right now, man,
you would have to have test results.
I'm really good at picking
out who's been really wild
and who's actually been quarantining,
because I was here when it was a hot spot,
when New York was a hot spot.
I'm a ninja with the quarantine.
I'm cold blooded with it, man.
I dodge 'rona.
And how you ask, you
don't ask straight out
because people will lie.
You just get them real comfortable.
You just ask stuff like,
"Man, this is crazy.
"This quarantine thing
is driving me crazy.
"I would just love to kick it
"with some people at a little
party, you know what I mean?
"Just like on the low",
and then they'll something, this happened.
She was like, "Yeah, you shoulda
been with us last weekend.
"We went up to this cabin,
but don't tell anybody".
I'm like, "I won't, and
I'll see you in 2021,
"you reckless (beeping)".
(laughing)
You dirty, ew!
You dirty, I knew you was outside!
So it's your own sting operation.
Yes, it is.
Well, it sounds like you're
in a lonely period right now,
but that's okay.
Yeah, very lonely.
I've watched porn so much
I think I've seen all of it
and I've started sending script notes.
(laughing)
Like, I don't see the
passion in their eyes.
I don't believe this.
Yeah, yeah.
First of all, that's something
to say you've watched all the porn.
All the porn that relates to me, yes.
It's like, is it HD, is it 4KHD?
We don't actually need
it to be that clear.
I don't want to see and
hear someone crying.
I don't need that, you know?
(laughing)
I'm glad that we started this conversation
with you raising so much money
for COVID-19 Protest Relief Fund,
and then, as always with me,
we end up talking about pornography
and how it could be better.
(laughing)
Well, I am thrilled.
You're doing such amazing stuff.
I mean as an artist, but
also getting involved
and doing what you're doing.
I really do salute you.
I just want to get the message out.
You can support the
COVID-19 Protest Relief Fund
by going to covid19protestrelief.com.